Hey, Jackman.
Listen, guys, don't make this tacky.
Nobody call them Wolverine.
and you just Wolverine right
now. Yeah. Feel that?
I think so. Does Wolverine hurt?
A little every time.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This will be my fall. Rick and Morty.
Season seven Episode one Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
references,
celebrity cameos like Hugh Jackman
with a whole bunch of Wolverine jokes.
So we'll break it all down.
I know there's also a bunch of questions
about what happened with Justin Roiland
being fired by the show in the New Voice.
Actors for Rick and Morty.
it is definitely the elephant in the room.
But I feel like they actually did
probably about as good
a job is finding sound alikes
as they possibly could.
So we'll address that in a second.
it is going to be a little bit weird
watching the show for a while.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
there's actually a bunch of banger
animated shows coming up later this year,
like Invincible Season two is happening.
I'll be doing episode videos
for that as well.
careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet,
but just starting with that elephant
in the room, the new voice actors playing
Rick and Morty are Ian Cardone,
who's playing Rick
and all the other Rick related characters
like the Rick's from different Universes,
like Rick, Prime
Harry Belden is the new voice actor
playing Morty in all the other Morty's
in some of the characters
that Justin also voiced like Justin voiced
a lot of different characters on the show,
so they might divide
some of those other characters
between these two new voice actors.
I can synthesize coffee.
You don't need to make excuses.
Yeah, I need to say that.
So I didn't even bring a cup.
I will say
just after watching this first episode,
I haven't seen
any of the other episodes yet,
but the Morty voice actor
sounds exactly like Morty.
he even kind of
looks like a grown up version of Morty.
Not to make fun of him
or anything like that.
This actually looks like a real life
version of Morty
the voice actor for Rick doesn't
sound exactly like Rick.
Like it's a little bit different.
You can pick up on it
if you've been watching the show
since season one really carefully,
but if you only been loosely
watching the show,
you might not notice it that much.
Generally, it didn't bother me.
I feel like they did a pretty decent job
given everything that's happened.
I'm not going to speak too much
on the Justin Roiland of it all.
That all kind of going down
in the background for the most part.
Dan Harmon also did a much bigger
interview addressing all that stuff
and basically confirmed
what a lot of the reports were saying,
what happened behind the scenes
that Rick and Morty in the drama
between him and Justin after season two.
Dan Harmon basically confirmed that
Justin had not been involved with the show
creatively since after season two?
Like he basically checked out and would
just come in and do the voiceover roles.
So generally starting with season three,
the show has completely been
Dan Harmon's creative vision.
the interview
that they don't represent in this episode,
there is a Rick and Morty movie
that they're also working on.
I don't know
when it's going to happen, but.
Dan Harmon also said that Zack Snyder
called him into his office
at Warner Brothers
to see if he could try to help him
get the Rick and Morty movie made.
because apparently Zack Snyder
is a Rick and Morty fanboy, Dan Harmon
basically explained that a Rick and Morty
movie would be just like South Park
bigger, longer and uncut,
like a completely separate
standalone adventure, maybe loosely
referencing some canonical stuff,
but the actual episode title
episode one was called
How Boobie Got His Poop Back,
which is a reference to the movie
How Stella Got Her Groove Back in
Rick helping PBE clean up his life
as he's basically hit rock bottom again
during the episode.
They also reference
all the events of his past,
which are basically the events
of all the different post-credits
scenes from different seasons.
Like sometimes he's out,
sometimes he's down.
And this time he is very down.
the last time we saw him,
Rick got him fired from his professor job.
And that's
what got him off the wagon again
in this downward spiral
where you find him here
in their living room.
that's
basically what the cold open is like,
finding him in their living room
where he's been living for a while now.
space
Beth is hanging out with the family again.
It seems like she's been with them on
the regular for a couple of seasons now.
she's probably still
in that weird relationship with Beth.
It's not anything that Rick or the other
characters haven't gotten up to.
So like, it's
normal for the Rick and Morty Universe
and the whole idea is that she's cut from
the same cloth is really
she's meant to be just like Rick.
So anything that Rick has done,
Beth is also probably either going to do
or has done already.
the other funny thing
too, is that since all this space, Beth
and Beth relations stuff
has been happening, that's basically
what they're doing on the Loki series
in the Marvel Universe.
Like Loki trying to get busy
with another version of himself
from another universe,
Jerry still using a TiVo.
If you're too young to remember
what TiVo is, it's basically a special DVR
that people use to record broadcast
TV shows before the age of streaming
became a thing in his defense
Jerry acknowledges that it is an antique.
let me know in the comments
if you still have a TiVo inside
your house somewhere,
even if you don't use it.
Pubs?
Dealer also tries to sell Rick and Morty
some R*talin.
That's why she asked
if they have trouble focusing in.
The whole idea here is that
they're mad at Rick
because he's been putting off
having an intervention for poopy b*tthole.
the episode is all about
getting over your own demons,
Dealing with your past in The irony is, is
that Rick has all those problems
he can't get over his past, it.
He's also just as lousy a drunk as PB is.
Pretty much all their friend group is zoom
in and hands around the living room.
There's a Custody Law for Dummies book
because he lost his son
when his wife left him
and he fell off the wagon.
the bathrobe he's wearing.
Seems like it belongs to Morty
because it has the M on it,
and they're about the same size.
Then he asked best help hang himself.
And it makes fun of her for being too poor
or too lazy to actually get a fan.
breaks the fourth wall again.
He's one of the few characters like Rick
who break the fourth wall all the time.
He even breaks
the fifth wall later in the episode,
then when he's recapping the events
of all of his post-credits scenes
and all the bad things
that have happened to him,
he recounts Beth shooting him when she's
still traumatized by in apparently
since the last time we saw him, he's
tried and failed to pass the bar exam.
That's the exam in the United States
that you tried to pass to become a lawyer.
there's an entire cabinet of booze
under the TV.
I think that's meant to belong
to Beth or Rick or maybe both of them,
because they're like the only two people
in the family that are lousy drunks.
there are a whole bunch of new intro
scenes.
Some are picking Rick out,
being super strong.
She's not quite as small
as when they were back in season two.
She's also got some risk device on her,
which is probably how she got super big.
Rick and Morty digging graves,
fighting off zombies, Beth in space, Beth
dancing in some kind of king's
court, all dressed up in candy in sweets
themed attire.
look back there, Morty and Summer seem
like they're having a good time.
For whatever reason, Space Beth is pissed.
Housewife Beth is afraid like
their lives are on the line or something.
Rick and Morty
skiing down a slope, escaping from people.
James Bond style.
But their heads are huge in their skiing
or snowboarding on their tongues.
Then Jerry
doing a big parody of Jean-Claude
Van Damme with the splits here.
Let me know in the comments
which of these intro scenes
you think are real and which are fake.
The other joke too, is that the fake intro
seems like the ones that don't wind up
in actual episodes might wind up
in like distant future episodes.
So like, they haven't happened yet.
So technically they could all be real.
the other big change to the intro here
that you probably noticed
is that Dan and Justin's names got taken
out of the opening
title like their creator credits
for obvious reasons.
they kept their ones at the like.
Justin Roiland
name is at the end of the episode,
So he still getting paid
his creator credit on the show
like he's just not earning extra money
that he would have gotten
for being a voice actor
or writing on the show.
Then Morty finds Rick downstairs
in his secret subbasement
that we learned about last season,
looking for Rick Prime.
They make a bunch of jokes about him
finding and killing him,
but he's being sarcastic.
I don't know if this will wind up being
true. You can let me know in the comments.
Sometimes they'll do that
where like Rick will joke
about something in a sarcastic way,
but it'll be the show saying, yeah, no,
he actually did that.
He was telling the truth.
He just sounded sarcastic.
they made a really big deal
about a bunch of Rick Prime stuff
happening this season,
so they could actually just be blowing
past that.
The show does that all the time. Will
they be like, yeah, this canonical thing?
Yeah. We're never ever going to reference
that ever again.
the monitor. He's looking at those shows.
A copy of the former central finite curve
Evil Morty essentially destroyed that.
This is all Rick's ability to control it,
but I think he's just trying to track
Rick Prime's movements.
So I think that implies
that Rick Prime is still alive
when he says he knows
how to make someone leave,
this is a reference to him being
insufferable and driving people away.
that apparently
Rick knows how to create goes
and they confirm that ghosts do exist
in the Rick and Morty universe.
then Rick makes a bunch of jokes about
referencing the logic behind the ghost.
Like, okay,
we need to unpack all this logic here.
There's a bunch of science to be explored
in the reality of ghosts.
They do that same kind of joke
at the end of the episode
where he fades out
and then tries to explain the logic behind
actually being able to fade out
like it's an actual pill that you take.
this is a bit of a meta joke
about shows over explaining their jokes.
the way they explain him.
Creating the ghost though in this moment
is that he injects
with a bunch of unfinished business.
And if you watch a lot of ghost movies
or ghost TV shows,
one of the tropes of Ghost
is the reason
why you're supposed to become a ghost
and not go to heaven or hell
is because you have unfinished business
on the planet.
it apparently he injects
some daddy issues into this ghost.
Those are his unresolved issues.
The other thing that's kind of soft
confirms, too, is that robots are
the robot that Rick created has a soul
so that it can become a ghost,
because that's one of the other
big twists.
Like you have to have a soul
in order to become a ghost.
Robots Having Souls
is also a big question of a lot of sci
fi movies Do like do robots have souls?
Or can they get souls?
Rick makes a joke about interventions
only being 10% effective,
then tries to explain away
that he's not having intervention.
Even though he describes
having an intervention,
they imply some are currently
has no friends, which would only be true
if he's not friends with Tricia Lang
or Nancy anymore.
Maybe they stopped being friends after
Tricia told her she wanted to bang Jerry
a couple of seasons ago,
that would definitely make things awkward
between the two of them.
then Rick basically brings back
some of the biggest characters on the show
that everybody been asking
to come back for a long time now.
First he goes to Gearhead
who has a salacious gear
themed poster on the wall.
He's kind of a punching bag on the show,
just in general theme of things.
they finally bring back the squad
she character for real this time.
Everybody's been wondering
since season two
when they're actually going to bring him
back.
They've referenced him
in a couple of previous seasons,
like there was an alternate possible
future that Rick saw
where he was killed by squashy,
Squashy also appeared
in his memory with bird person of the war
when they fought together.
But this time he's back for real.
They make a bunch of jokes at his house,
too, about how he needs an intervention.
Just as bad is PBE needs one in.
Pretty much
everybody in the group is in dire
need of an intervention
like they're all meant to be.
Just as bad is he is there's a bunch of
empty bottles strewn around the room.
There's a giant bag of catnip
in a giant dong shaped bong.
the whole joke
during season two, during his wedding,
is that there were like a lot of dongs
and a lot of balls in the background.
So now when you rewatch those episodes,
you won't be able to unsee that.
when Rick sees him.
He also jokes about saying that he wasn't
dead.
That's mostly a wink at the fans.
Like, see, Spanky wasn't dead.
We brought him back.
they bring back bird person whole.
This time he's still voiced by Dan Harmon.
The last we saw of him, Rick
healed his body to its original state.
Then he learned about his daughter
leaving to find her who he's calling
Bird daughter
basically is half human daughter
with Tammy, the house he's living in
seems like the exact same one
that he used to live in.
he yells at her
for being super lazy and leaving Grantham
my pieces all over the place.
Apparently she's an assassin.
He jokes about finding her in a femme
fatale training camp.
They might be creating all this backstory
for the character
so that he can bring them back
and turn it into a bigger thing
in future seasons
bird person's joke about finding
a sober person for their group is because,
like I said, they're all meant to be
just as lousy drunks as P.B..
they use it as an excuse
to bring Gene back
Love the writing lore more Joe to that
they turn into the post-credits scene
like he won't let them stop it.
Which is another joke
about being super selfish.
Like bird person said,
I want to show my daughter
what real selfish people look like when
Rick is probably the most selfish person
you can think of. R.I.P.
to that dude on the motorcycle.
Then I couldn't think of
any specific references for the F-you
name of the bar, the middle finger,
but it's basically
like the most aggressive, most toxic bar
you could possibly think of.
this is a what looks like a copyright safe
sign in the background,
which might be them calling out somebody
in real life for trying to sue the show
for like some logo that appeared
in an episode like We dare you to sue us
like they're giving the middle finger
to somebody
in real life,
daring them to sue the show. in no.
I do not think that they're giving
Justin Roiland the middle finger
because they would have done this
episode long
before they actually had to fire them off
the show P.B.
has apparently been stalking his wife,
who's been seeing her plays instructor
for a little while before she winds up
seeing the Predator it.
Apparently now, predators are keen in
to the Rick and Morty Universe.
he hires one to track his wife.
They make a joke
about his old website from 2001.
that might be a joke about all the time
between Predator movies.
Like The Predator was out of work
after Predator two in the early nineties
and didn't work again
to the Next Predator movie in 2004.
they wind up turning into a much bigger
joke.
Later, he falls in love with his wife
in search of a relationship and becomes
his wife's new family.
Basically, that's actually the plot
of some trippy movies.
The bartender makes a Gilligan's Island
reference
because Jean does
look kind of like the Gilligan character.
He says PBE looks like an eraser
because he kind of looks like an eraser
and basically proceeds to make fun of him
calling out all the terrible things
that have happened to him
without realizing
that he's telling the truth.
PB uses the lie about his birthday
to prove
that they're not really his best friends
because they all forgot.
Love the seen them all remember it like,
Wait a minute, it was your birthday.
All crap to be fair,
it was not his actual birthday.
So they shouldn't be slighted
for not remembering that.
Then they go on a big hangover
style bender, like a big montage.
They travel to a bottle themed universe.
Basically,
they're drinking their blood here.
So R.I.P.
to all these cans and bottles
won't have drinking,
but it looks like some of Jean's piss.
And then they go to a honey rave
and basically do a parody of the opening
scene of the Blade movie
with all the BS Giving us a giant.
Hugh Jackman cameo scene.
And it's actually Hugh Jackman
doing the voice,
even though it doesn't sound exactly
like him.
But Hugh Jackman has done
voiceover roles before.
there's actually a Hugh Jackman, Rick
and Morty connection that predates this.
So Hugh Jackman just starred
in an animated show called Koala
Man that was created by Michael Cusack.
he's the person who did Bush World
Adventures, the parody version
of Rick and Morty.
so apparently actor Hugh
Jackman is now canon to the Rick and Morty
universe as are his X-Men movies.
All the other movies
he's done they make a reference to Rick
hosting the Oscars, which he did recently.
They make a bunch of Wolverine jokes,
basically making fun of all of his movies.
and apparently Gene is now related
to Hugh Jackman through Hugh Jackman's
former wife, now former when they recorded
the episode, they were still married.
but Deborra-Lee Furness used to be
his wife and was Jean's cousin.
in fact, now because of what happened
with Hugh Jackman in real life,
getting divorced from his wife
or about to get divorced,
it's a little bit more relevant,
the way his character acts during this
when they're talking about PB
and his wife's relationship,
generally
his character is all over the map.
Like sometimes he's a super big b*tthole
who's super selfish in
sometimes he says really sincere things,
like he's all over
the spectrum in the episode,
like super over-the-top, ridiculous.
Hugh Jackman
they make a joke about him
calling his dumps huge ackman's
because ackman's apparently
in the universe of Rick and Morty
or Australian slang for dumps
the obvious joke is
it is a play on his name basically
calling himself a piece of crap
in apparently in this universe
he is a total party monster, making them
take a bunch a bunch of mystery pills
that cause them to hallucinate
like Rick's fingers sing in the lame,
his style, the way that Hugh Jackman
also does when he returns at his house.
They have a bunch of parody movie posters
of all the X-Men Wolverine stuff,
all of his Miz stuff
The X-Men poster is called Jackman.
It is basically Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
But as all the different characters,
I think
this is meant to be a meta commentary
on how the popularity
of his Wolverine character
kind of took over all the X-Men movies.
At a certain point,
like all the movie posters, even The Miz
poster has him as Cosette on the cover.
So it's meant to be like super eight,
like making it all about himself.
There's pictures of him
and his former wife.
I don't think they got divorced
when they actually recorded the episode.
Him with the Rock.
There's a bunch of awards that he's won.
there's even a golden pair of Wolverine
claws
He's got a giant naked poster of himself
with the Wolverine claws.
But here's the thing.
It looks like the Wolverine claws
or actually in his head,
like he actually has Wolverine claws.
It was just walking around
naked one day, like
he doesn't have the Wolverine haircut.
So this is like him on a normal day.
And he actually has Wolverine claws.
they start a big running gag
with Billy Ocean's Caribbean Queen song
saying that Hugh Jackman or Hugh
Jackman tells that he actually wrote
the song originally in it's
actually on his Grammy Award for aged 16.
The joke there is that Hugh
Jackman was 16 in 1984.
That's the year
that Caribbean Queen was published.
when he calls Ric an energy vampire,
they actually have one of those on
what we do in the shadows.
He basically sucks people's energy.
Hugh Jackman makes a joke about Wolverine.
And when they say that
it hurts every time,
that's a reference to the Wolverine movies
because Wolverine,
every time he pops his claws, it
basically hurts really bad
because when the claws come out, they have
to push through his muscle in his skin.
And then it has to heal
when he retracts the claws.
So like, every time he pops them,
he cuts himself.
they go to his ex-wife's house.
And Hugh Jackman actually sings Caribbean
Queen in a parody of Say Anything,
the John Cusack movie it apparently is
beginning freaky with Her predator,
which I think they've used that twist
in a couple of actual movies
He kidnaps his son, they do a bigger
parody of the first Predator
movie with them covering themselves
in mud to hide from him and do a big fight
that basically goes down the way
the fights in the first Predator movie
with Arnold Schwarzenegger
go down couples.
DRE Really funny moments
during the actual fight, like he rips off
gearheads
nuts and stuffs them in his mouth.
the predator taking his armor
and weapons off is a twist
from the first Predator movie.
PBC Season four Episode three References.
When they showed his fighting abilities
where he actually ended up getting fired
from that professor job in.
It's also an example of him
breaking the fifth wall like Rick
does every once in a while,
basically someone referencing
that they know
they're a character
in a fictional TV show.
that's like another level
beyond just addressing the audience,
breaking the fourth wall
then they reveal that the Predator
is now like in a family relationship,
like his son
thinks of the Predator as his father
The musket
joke is from the end of Predator two
then PBE makes peace with his wife
and is basically ready to move on
with his life until Hugh
Jackman comes back and almost kills.
Kind of seems like he killed the predator.
And if it wasn't clear,
Dan Harmon was also doing
the Voice of the Predator Because I must.
But man possesses a precious gift.
who actually seems like a pretty chill
dude R.I.P., if he did wind up dying,
they steal a car,
go to a version of Taco Bell.
Apparently, Taco Bell didn't
want to pay Rick and Morty any money.
So that's why they didn't use actual
Taco Bell.
Everybody goes their separate ways, but
they do like a funny end credits scene.
VOICEOVER where PB basically narrates
things from the distant future
about everybody's adventures.
After this moment, bird person
makes a joke about the canon of the show.
Like meeting you here seemed canonical.
he goes off to save his daughter
who's at a federation compound.
like I said,
they might be trying to set them up
for a bigger storyline in future seasons.
I think what they crave
so much new backstory for this daughter
The show also calls out itself
for making too many Hugh Jackman Wolverine
jokes, saying that Hugh Jackman went off
to try and prevent future Wolverine jokes
from happening
saying that they basically ruined it
with all the references on this show,
like never again.
Hugh Jackman is never going
to do something like that again.
probably is also going off in universe
to make Deadpool three like
Deadpool is also probably canon
to the universe of Rick and Morty.
If the X-Men movies are canon,
all the fade out transitions, though,
are a trope of a lot of classic TV shows.
But then Rick tries to overexplain
like he did earlier in the episode,
Explain the logic behind Ghost Explained.
The logic behind the Beatles
is if it's an actual feel like, See,
I had to take this pill to fade back in
and I'm going to take another one
to fade back out PB Then
fading out saying that it felt like
he was basically being burned alive.
then the post-credits scene,
they pay off the joke about jeans riding
more still running like it won't stop
and it's destroyed an entire town,
but it's just about to run out of gas
like nobody has bothered
to just get out of his way.
I think the cop is meant to be a reference
to Sam Elliott.
Like he looks just like Sam Elliott.
He also has a bunch of medallions.
Like one of them is
the world's most superstitious person
making a joke about
how he basically let himself get run over
instead of moving out of the way
because literally runs out of gas
the minute that it hits them.
the like I said, important to note
during the vanity and credits cards,
Justin, Rowan's name is still there,
like he's still getting paid
his creator credit
for co-creating the show with Dan Harmon.
I think Dan Harmon's vanity card has been
the same for a couple of seasons now.
This is him
and his fiancee in his dogs in real life,
there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references, if there are any.
In the episode that you spotted
that I didn't talk about
the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My only real criticism of the show is it
didn't need to lean so hard on the over
the top Hugh Jackman of it all.
Like it's fun to have celebrity cameos,
But the cameos are usually better
when they're playing new characters,
not actually playing over-the-top
versions of themselves.
but it was cool that Hugh
Jackman came to do the show.
my episode to video will post next week
after they release it.
Another big reminder, Invincible Season
two episodes will start really soon.
I'll be doing
weekly episode videos for that.
It is probably one of the best
new animated shows.
Click Here for my new Invincible Season
2 trailer video
and Easter Eggs and click here
for all my Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!